all right it's stafford gamut time
wait did you want to be white or black
okay you want to be black
all right i'll play the magical line
i'm curious now
how do i play the magical line bishop e2
okay so this is a line i've had
i've had more on the black side
i feel like i played roster boss where
we had the game g3 queen h3 and then
bishop f1
that was a magical connect 8 game
but here i'll go for
bishop h or bishop to f3
let's see what what ross has in store
[Music]
oh bishop d7 is what ross played against
me in the past
um
i mean i should probably just bite take
the bishop
okay let's let's see what uh what's in
store here
so castling queenside
now how scary is this
so i have queen e2
i think we need to is a
a reasonably safe option
and we played this like
the same thing at some point i think
i'm gonna bishop f4
the problem is if i move bishop g2 then
bishop g4
like white could already be in trouble
trouble there which
is kind of crazy
and even with this line like takes takes
g5
wait a minute
am i lost
i have to be really careful
[Music]
i don't know if i can take that
am i just losing here
that's crazy if i'm already just losing
the second game in a row
i want to play this but i get made in
one move
and the problem
i was so focused on g5 i forgot there's
bishop g4
so i think i have to run this way
that's not what i want
i could take and take
i am up a piece
like get
two pieces for a queen
okay i'm gonna play this
this is super super dangerous
and then
probably this move
so ross came prepared
where did i go wrong
it's a cool idea though
bishop was pinned and the queen was
stuck maybe like
maybe bishop f4 swooner in 92.
okay this is gonna be interesting
because i can take the bishop
and then take the knight
i take with check
and then this move
wait
wait what did i do
no i only have two pieces for the queen
why did i think i have three
okay i'm in trouble again
[Music]
i should not have played that so like
quickly and confidently
oh no
[Music]
i'm still alive kind of
hey it's taki what's up tagi
if you're just joining i'm in a little
bit of trouble
russell boss might be beating me with a
staffer now
why is my pawn hanging
cats play for
so many pawns are hanging
we're playing no increment either
i should have taken this a little bit
more seriously
oh
no
okay rook a3
negro ga3
start throwing pieces
how many things am i down i'm down
queen and three pawns for bishop and
knights
and down a lot of time
but apart from that maybe things are
okay
i don't know what my plan is
e5
hey it's on poisson
hey maybe i'm winning a pawn
[Music]
unless queen takes
okay some progress
it's still really bad though
um
okay i have to make it so the bishop
defends the rook
and defends the pawn which in turn
defends the bishop
if you're maybe here
i mean we might see the sock
wow
queen here
i might use to play this though
ensuring everything's defended
don't perpet me
i think i'm playing for a win now
that might be hard to play for a win if
i get per padded
um
okay
not exactly what i want
there we go
okay
one second left
oh i was getting crushed though
i was really close
good game rasta boss
also respect for not repeating
it was really close to repetition there
oh man
i threw man that was insane
your opening prop was insane
i know we played this once before and
the last time i also got a losing
position
engine says it's really really good for
white
but
has this occurred on lichas
wait
oh
okay so
wait
okay i found our game from four months
ago
where i also i played knight d2
which loses to bishop h3
which is crazy
this game i play bishop f4 which also
just loses my dog krieger says
hi oh hi to krieger
also wolf wolf to krieger
wolf wolf to all the dogs watching right
now
[Music]
man so there's there's a few ways light
can go wrong
wait queenie two is already of losing
queen e2 is already losing
queen e2 looks so natural too
bh3 was my prep if nd2 then i sack
winning background
so i'm supposed to just leave my queen
develop
visually 3 is like a weird move to play
though
so it just allows this
and then allows discoveries it feels
really wrong to leave the queen
aligned with a rook
that's nice crap man i feel inspired to
use this
because the move i've been playing
recently
if you look at my black games
is bishop e6
with idea that after he takes
then the bishop's a little bit better
placed
a lot of people play queen e2 which
loses to knight e5
i think there's yeah there's only a
couple games here
and it hasn't been so well explored the
queen e2 is the most played move
i want to put this on youtube i want to
call the youtube video i got crushed
with the staffer gambit
bd7 has some crazy discovery ideas which
is why i love it so much
uh
yeah i mean especially if white
like the top engine moves aren't so
intuitive
i guess 92 though but black's still
getting
still getting some compensation
like knight e5
if bishop g2 then man knight d3
so bishop e2 but then bishop h3 and
white's a little bit stuck
yeah i'll have to
to look into this bishop
d7 move
okay yeah hello to future people on
youtube
shout out to rasabos
if you're watching in the future on
youtube
you can meet me and rossavos in vegas
i'll leave a link in the description
vegas chess festival in june